- I'm Mike and I think
ghosts are bull (beep).
(relaxed music)
- What would the ghosts look like?
I saw Ghostbusters, like Slimer?
- Sometimes, people lose loved ones.
They're attached to the idea that
they could find their loved ones
in the paranormal form.
- In the entire course of
people owning cameras,
we don't have one piece of evidence
that ghosts exist.
- If I'm scared, it's
because I'm in the dark
in the middle of nowhere.
- The only thing I'm afraid of at night
is a criminal coming up to me
and stabbing me in the throat.
- I'm nervous, my heart is
palpitating a little bit.
- I heard that ghosts get
angry when they see red.
So, I'm human bait.
Come at me, ghosts.
- It's gonna be fun.
(sigh)
(suspenseful music)
- I have a Ghostbusters pillowcase at home
that I believe is real.
But ghosts are not real.
We're here at the
supposed abandoned asylum.
We're about to go inside.
(ominous music)
- My name is Chad.
I'm co-founder of Amendella Paranormal.
- I'm Josh, I'm the founder.
- This is an asylum
that I had found before.
It's been kinda locally known.
- There's no actual address to this place.
No real roads here.
- [Chad] Literally in
the middle of nowhere.
- There's no actual evidence
of this being an asylum.
It's all folklore.
- How you feeling, Jason?
- I'm feeling great.
I'm actually more
interested in the graffiti.
- We're going to be going in through here.
Everybody be careful.
- A couple things that we've gotten here,
we've gotten a lot of voices.
Me and Daniel actually
heard a little boy laughing.
- We've gotten EMF hits here,
confirming that there is some spirit
that either believes they're
a nurse or was once a nurse.
You will probably find that you'll
wanna stay closer to the walls.
Most people feel better in the dark
when they have something behind them.
- Just keep your mind
open, keep your ears open.
Sometimes you'll feel like a slight touch,
a breath, or, it's real
subtle, you know what I mean?
- Is it just me, or does
everyone now feel like
they're feeling breaths and touches?
(laughter)
(mechanical beeping)
- [Voiceover] So.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, so it's on now.
(faint whistling sound)
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] Someone
trying to whistle, or?
- [Voiceover] Definitely heard that.
- [Voiceover] What was it?
Yeah, so it's on now.
(whistling sound)
- [Voiceover] You heard
it, though, the whistling?
- [Voiceover] I heard
it, oh yeah, for sure.
- [Voiceover] What was it?
- [Voiceover] I thought it was like,
a cell phone or something.
- [Voiceover] I don't know.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, so it's on now.
- [Voiceover] Right.
(dramatic bangs)
- [Voiceover] So we know the nurses here,
do you get lonely here by yourself,
or are you by yourself?
- [Voiceover] What was that?
- [Voiceover] The moan or whatever?
- I thought I heard a moan.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, it--
- I heard something, there was just like
a big atmospheric boom.
- [Voiceover] Right here, right?
- Yeah.
- [Voiceover] We brought a lot of people
that are very anxious to meet you.
- [Voiceover] We're here
to make them believers.
Are you gonna help us with that?
Can you finish this for me?
(slaps)
(dramatic bangs)
- [Voiceover] What if
you use the spirit box?
- Well, we got that one.
I think I hear something.
- Speak louder, please.
Damn, we're really not
getting anything right now.
(dramatic bangs)
- [Voiceover] I could see
this being fun to hang out at
during the day.
- [Voiceover] All right,
everybody let's get in a circle.
Hi, you can use our energy.
Can you come over here and grab one of us?
Did nobody feel anything yet?
- My wrist got a little itchy.
- [Voiceover] Want me to get that for you?
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] Can you make
it colder in the circle?
- [Voiceover] 73.8.
(beeping)
Okay, now's it's 73 even.
72.3.
- [Voiceover] Keep going, keep going.
- [Voiceover] So it's a
four degree difference?
- Yeah. 71.6.
70.9.
- [Voiceover] 69.
- [Voiceover] It dropped seven degrees.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] In the middle
of a circle of people--
- [Voiceover] It should get hotter.
- [Voiceover] It should never be colder,
it should be warmer.
- [Voiceover] Can we
do 95 degrees, please?
(laughter)
(dramatic bangs)
(dramatic piano music)
- I didn't personally see anything
or experience anything.
- It was just like a teen hangout spot.
I wouldn't have been
surprised if we walked in
on two teenagers making out.
- And when you look up
and you see the stars
and the stars are
actually pretty beautiful.
This is really awesome,
I should go camping here.
- I was creeped out by
imagining the past of the place.
I was creeped out by imagining what
might have gone on there.
- Paranormal or not,
there's just something
off-putting about that.
- I dug their enthusiasm.
I thought it was cool
they were so into this.
- Being alone in a
mysterious, creepy place,
that would make me more afraid.
- It's all about the power of the mind.
If you're afraid of something,
you're probably gonna force that to exist
somehow in your mind.
- You can believe whatever you want.
I'm not gonna be the one to be like,
"You're fake, you're bull, whatever."
- There's a world of things
humans can't perceive.
Could ghosts theoretically
be one of those thing?
Sure, but that's just as likely as like,
cat monsters that eat squids.
(quiet piano music)
- It's just so sad what's
happening over there.
- Oh yeah, mm-hmm.
Hmmm.
You don't know the half of it.